ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้า
สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดี
ค่ะก็กลับมาเจอกับเรา 2 คนเนาะครูหญิง
แล้วก็ครูฟ้านะคะในวีดีโอระดับอะไรคะใน
วีดีโอระดับบีกินเนอร์ค่ะดีน่อขายอาหาร
ครูฟ้าคะวันนี้วันอะไรคะ
วันนี้วันพุธที่
1 พุธที่เท่าไหร่คะวันพุธที่ 2 ค่ะเดือน
อะไรคะเดือน
กุมภาพันธ์
มีนาคม
เวลาคบ
มีนาคมนะเรียนมีได้ 2 ปีพปีพศ.อะไรคะปี
พ.ศ
เต็มนะคะปีคศอะไรคะปีคศ 2  022 ค่ะเมื่อ
วานนี้วันอะไรคะครูฟ้า
เมื่อวานนี้วันอังคารค่ะวันอังคารวันที่
เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 1
เดือน
เดือนมีนาคมปีพตต
2565 ปีคศ 2  022 ค่ะค่ะแล้วพรุ่งนี้วัน
อะไรคะพรุ่งนี้วันพฤหัสบดี
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 3 ค่ะดีเดือน
มีนาคม
ปีพปีพศ.
2565 ปีคศ
2  022 ค่ะ
สวัสดีก็วัน
ใช่ไหมคะแล้วตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะครูฟ้าตอน
นี้เวลา 11:00 น
11:00 นกี่นาทีคะ
23 นาทีค่ะ
11:00 น 23 นาทีเนาะครูฟ้ากินข้าวหรือ
ยัง
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยยังไม่ได้กินข้าวไหมคะมีหญิง
ไม่ได้กินข้าวครูฟ้าหิวไหมคะ
ครูฟ้าหิวข้าวมาก
หิวมาก
กินข้าวแล้วอยากกินข้าวแล้วค่ะหิวข้าว
ดีแล้วครูฟ้าเนี่ยทำกับค่าทำอาหารใช่ไหม
ทำอาหารที่บ้านที่บ้านกูฟ้าน้องเอเอนะทำ
อาหารที่บ้านหรือว่าบีครูฟ้าเนี่ยต้องไป
ที่
ไม่ใช่กี่ราะดีและก็คือคู่ฟ้าต้องไปซื้อ
อาหารข้างนอกบ้านจะไม่อาจจะเป็น
ซุปเปอร์มาร์เก็ตเซเว่นอีเลฟเว่นเส้นไหม
คะ Terminal เซ็นทรัลครูฟ้าต้องไปซื้อ
ครูฝาต้องไปซื้ออาหารข้างนอกบ้านค่ะอ่อน
ไม่ได้กินที่บ้านใช่ไหม
ไม่แล้วจากบ้านน้องบ้านครูฟ้าแล้วก็กูฟ้า
ก็ไปสมุดไปเซ็นทรัล
ไปเซ็นทรัลไปซื้ออาหาร
ครูฟ้าไปยังไงอ่ะคุณครูฟ้าเนี่ย
มี 2  Choice นะ
มี 3  Choice ที่ 2 จอยส์มี 3 ช้อยอีช้อย
นี้ 3  Choice ก็ได้
กูมาคิดก่อนคิดมีกี่สร้อย 3
ช้อยก็ได้ค่ะมี 3 ซอยใช่ไหมคะอะไรบ้างอ่ะ
หนึ่ง
หนึ่งก็คือ
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยให้คุณพ่อ
คุณพ่อนะคะกูค่ะมี
นี้อันนี้ครูฟ้าเนาะ
ครูฟ้าแล้วก็มีคุณพ่อคุณแม่ก็คือกูฟ้าให้
คุณพ่อ
คุณพ่อเนี่ยขับรถ
ขับรถนะคะำ Honda  Yamaha
Mercedes  Benz
BMW อะไรเนี่ยรถให้เดี๋ยวพ่อขับรถ
เช้าพ่อขับรถไปปล่อยที่ 2 ซอยที่ 2 อะไร
Choice ที่ 2 ในคู่ฟ้าขี่มอเตอร์ไซค์
มีมอเตอร์ไซค์บุญบริโอ้ฟ้าขี่มอเตอร์ไซค์
ไปขี่มอเตอร์ไซค์ค่ะเขาในที่ 3 ใช่มั้ย
วันที่ 3  Choice ใช่ไหมคะ I เขาว่าอยู่ 3
Choice  Choice ที่ 3 ก็คือ
เรียกแกร็บแท็กซี่
แก๊ปไบค์
อ๋อ
ก็คือมีแอพพลิเคชั่นโอ๋
ๆ
มีแอพพลิเคชั่นแกร๊บแล้วก็ครูฟ้าก็เรียก
แร็พใช่ไหมแกร๊บก็จะขับเป็นแกร๊บค่าหรือ
ว่าแกรปไบค์คะเป็น Grab  Bike หาแป๊บบาย
บ๊ายบายก็คือแกร๊บก็จะขี่มอเตอร์ไซค์รุ่น
มารับร้านค้าทาร้ายใช่ค่ะว่าใน
แอพพลิเคชั่นแกร๊บๆนะคะ
แอพพลิเคชั่น Grab เหนียวโหมันก็มืดเกิน
ไปนะเนี่ย
ลำบาก
โอ้ย Application วันจะมี
นี่ไหมเป็น
แล้วก็จะมีให้เราเลือกเลือกนะว่าเราจะไป
ที่ไหน
แบบนี้เลยแล้วก็จะมีให้เลือก Rap  by กับ
ข่าอะไรอย่างนี้ครูฟ้าก็มี 3  Choice ใช่
ไหมอันที่ 1 ก็คือให้คุณพ่อขับรถ
รักซอยที่ 2 ครูฟ้าขี่มอเตอร์ไซค์ไปที่ 3
แกรปไบค์ขี่มอเตอร์ไซค์มาหาครูฟ้ามารับ
ใช่ฟ้านะครับถ้าอย่างนั้นน่ะครูฟ้าครูฟ้า
เนี่ยก็ขน่าจะใส่ได้สิคะเพราะว่าใช้ที่
สองรูฟ้าบอกว่าครูฟ้าจะขี่มอเตอร์ไซค์ใช่
ไหมคะมีนี่คือฟ้าหรือเปล่าคะเนี่ย
ไม่ใช่ค่ะเพราะไม่ใส่หมวก
นี่เนาะ
มอเตอร์ไซค์นี่ขี่มอเตอร์ไซค์ขี่
มอเตอร์ไซค์ครูฟ้าเนี่ย
ขี่มอเตอร์ไซค์ได้ให้ค่ะนักเรียนครูบาขี่
มอเตอร์ไซค์ได้โอ้โห
ครูฟ้าก็เลยคิดถ้าครูฟ้าหิวใช่ไหมอยากกิน
ข้าวกูฟ้าก็ขี่มอเตอร์ไซค์ไปซื้อได้ไอ
เซียนแต่ซื้อ
เวลาครูฟ้าขี่มอเตอร์ไซค์ภูฟ้าใส่หมวกไหม
คะหมวกกันน็อคหมวกกันน็อค
ไม่ใส่ล่ะอ่ะก็ไม่ได้ครูฟ้าขี่
มอเตอร์ไซค์ต้องใส่หมวกกันน็อก a  Safety
First แล้วมันใกล้ๆ
500 เมตร
500 เมตรใกล้ๆไว้ขี่มอเตอร์ไซค์ประมาณ 2
นาทีโอเคมั้ยก็ไม่ได้กูฟ้าถึงแม้ว่าที่
บ้านครูฟ้าอ่ะแล้วฟ้าก็จะไป
ซุปเปอร์มาร์เก็ต
500 เมตรจะไป 500 เมตรขี่มอเตอร์ไซค์แค่
2 นาที
ปูฟ้าก็ต้องใส่หมวกกันน็อกแบบนี้ใช่ไหม
หมวกกันน็อก
ไม่รู้
ทำให้อยู่ให้เราชายไม่รู้ว่า
ชายค่ะครูฟ้าขี่มอเตอร์ไซค์ดีได้ไหมอ่ามี
แต่คนอื่นไม่รู้นะแต่ครูหญิงก็รู้ว่าครู
ฟ้าเนี่ยขี่มอเตอร์ไซค์ได้
ได้กุมารขี่มอเตอร์ไซค์ได้ค่ะเก่งไหมคะ
ถูกอ่าขี่มอเตอร์ไซค์เก่งไหมก็โอเคนะเก่ง
ไหมหรอไม่ได้นิดหน่อยหน่อยเจ๋งนิดหน่อย
อ่าว่าเวลากูฟ้าขี่มอเตอร์ไซค์ใน
ในแบบว่า
ซอยเล็กๆใช่ไหมเหมือนว่าจะลองว่าใน patch
อยู่นักเรียนจะเห็น
กุมารขี่มอเตอร์ไซค์เก่งนิดหน่อยถ้าเกิด
เบนซ์
เราบอกว่า
เป็นถนน
มันเป็นถนน
การให้กูสาวาทก่อนไงถนน
อยู่ถนน 2 เลนเนี่ยโอเคนะคะไปแล้วก็กลับ
นี้โอเค
ขี่มอเตอร์ไซค์แบบนี้กูว่าโอเคเก่งโอเค
แต่ว่า
ถ้าเกิดเป็น
ซีเรน
สีเรยเนี่ยกูพักหรูฮว่าต่อ 2 เขาบอกไม่
โอเคไม่โอเคกูกลัวๆก็เลยขี่มอเตอร์ไซค์
ได้หน่อยค่ะแล้วครูฟ้าเนี่ยขี่
มอเตอร์ไซค์ได้ตั้งแต่ครูฟ้าอายุเท่าไหร่
คะครูฟ้าอายุอายุเท่าไหร่ฟ้าขี่
มอเตอร์ไซค์กูไปขี่มอเตอร์ไซค์อายุ
19 ค่ะอ๋ออีกมั้ยอ้าวเจ้า
หรอกนะเด็กนักเรียนขี่มอเตอร์ไซค์ได้ไหม
ว่าในประเทศไทยเนี่ยขี่มอเตอร์ไซค์เยอะนะ
สายค่ะคุณคนคนๆขี่มอเตอร์ไซค์ประมาณ
70% แม่สายแล้วก็คนใครน้องคนไทยคนไทยมาก
ๆขี่มอเตอร์ไซค์ได้นะขี่มอเตอร์ไซค์ได้
ครูฟ้าขี่มอเตอร์ไซค์ได้นะคะๆค่ะครูหญิง
ขี่มอเตอร์ไซค์ได้ไหมคะผู้หญิงก็ขี่
มอเตอร์ไซค์ได้ค่ะนาครูฟ้าเนี่ยขี่
มอเตอร์ไซค์ได้คู่ฟ้า
ขี่จักรยานขี่จักรยานไหมคะปั่นจักรยาน
ปั่นจักรยานหรือว่าขี่จักรยานแต่กูฟ้า
ปั่นจักรยานหรือขี่จักรยานได้ไหมคะ
โอ้โหกูไฟล์ขี่จักรยานเก่งมาก
โอ้โหคุณฟ้าขี่ได้แล้วก็คีย์เก่งอันขี่
จักรยานนิทานนักเรียนนักเรียนจองนะคะถ้า
ครูหญิงที่แบบนี้อันนี้ก็ขี่จักรยาน
แล้วครูฟ้าอ่ะขี่จักรยานน็อกขี่จักรยาน
ได้
ตั้งแต่อายุเท่าไหร่คะอันนี้คงฟ้ายุ19
เนี่ยขี่มอเตอร์ไซค์ว่าขี้จักรยานอายุ
เท่าไหร่
อายุดูฟ้าขี่จักรยานอายุ 5 ขวบมั้งโต๋
[เพลง]
+ นักเรียน
จะเด็กๆเออ
เป็นอุทยาน
จักรยานแบบนี้ค่ะ
จักรยานแบบไหนคะที่คุณฟ้าเนี่ยขี่ได้ตอน
อายุ 5 ขวบ
อำเป็น
จักรยานแล้วทีเด็ดกูปลา
แป๊บนึงนะคะนักเรียนแป๊บนึงน่ารักเราบอก
ว่า
จักรยาน
[เพลง]
3 ล้อค่ะ
อันนี้เนี่ยจักรยานมี 1  2  2 ล้อแต่ครู
ฟ้าขี่จักรยาน 3 ล้อหรอคะ
ใช่ค่ะนั่นไม่โหลดอ้ะมันแบบนี้นะอ้า
จักรยานเด็กๆใช่ไหมมีหนึ่งมีข้างหน้าใช่
ไหมมีข้างหน้าหนึ่งล้อมีข้างหลังสองล้อ
ให้เธอแมะก็กระชาน 300 น่ะตอนเด็กๆไฟฟ้า
ก็ขี่จักรยานได้ใช่ไหมกูก็ขี้จักรยานตั้ง
แต่ 5 ขวบ
ผู้หญิงขี่จักรยานได้ไหมอ่ะการขี่จักรยาน
ได้ค่ะก็ขี่จักรยานท่านี้เนี่ยขี่จักรยาน
ได้ปั่นจะเป็นอย่างจ่ายครูฟ้าเนี่ยขี่
มอเตอร์ไซค์ได้เนาะขี่จักรยานได้
ขี่ม้าได้ไหมคะครูฟ้าขี่
ขี้ม้า
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยขี่ม้าไม่ได้ค่ะผู้หญิงไม่ได้
สะมะนี้ได้นะ
ฮะอะไรไม่เอา
ครูว่าครูบาขี่ม้าแบบนี้ใช่ไหมคะไม้
เกี่ยวกับเนี่ยไม่ได้แล้วครูฟ้าขี่ม้า
อะไรได้ครูฟ้าพูดอ้ะนักเรียนอยากรู้แล้ว
มาหมุน
ปากนักเรียนภาษาไทยของ
สูงนะมานี่มานี่ก็มา
ครูฟ้าขี่ม้าหมุนอะเนี่ยเรียกว่าม้าหมุน
ม้าหมุนม้าขี่ได้แต่ม้าแบบนี้ไม่ได้ line
อาหรือ
เราก็พูดขี่ในมาหมุนทำอะไรใส่ขี่ที่
แลนด์อะไรเงี้ย Universe  on ก็จะมีน้ำอด
ขี่ม้าหมุนไปขี่ม้าหมุนได้สมัยแต่ขี่หมาย
มาเป็นตัวกลัวฟ้าขี่ไม่ได้นะคะขี่ไม่ได้
แล้วขึ้นมาได้ไหมผู้หญิงขี่ม้าไม่ได้ค่ะ
ไม่ได้นะขี่ม้าหมุนได้
ครูฟ้าเนาะขี่มอเตอร์ไซค์ได้นะขี่จักรยาน
ได้เนาะขี่ม้าไม่ได้ดีแล้วครูฟ้า
ขับรถนะคะขับรถเนาะนี่เนี่ยเหมือนผู้หญิง
คนนี้นะคะผู้หญิงคนนี้เขาขับรถครูฟ้าขับ
รถได้ไหมคะขับรถเป็นไหม
กูพาขับรถไม่เป็นไม่ได้ไม่ได้น้องก็ขับรถ
ไม่ได้ขับรถไม่เป็นทำไมขับรถไม่เป็นไม่
เข้าใจทำยังไง
ไม่เข้าใจผู้หญิงนะคะกริ่งขับรถเป็นไหม
คุยก็ขับรถไม่เป็นนะเหมือนครูฟ้าสมัครไม่
เข้าใจกุญแจสตาร์ทเบรคเกียร์ไม่เข้าใจ
เนาะขับรถไม่เป็นใช่มั้ยครูฟ้าก็เลยถอย
ที่ 1 ไงครูฟ้าจะบอกว่าถ้าครูฟ้าหิวครู
ฟ้าก็ให้คุณพ่อมันขับรถสบายเพราะว่าคุณ
พ่อครูฟ้าขับรถเป็นตายเพราะว่าขับรถเป็น
นะคะขับรถเก่งคุณพ่อขับรถเก๋งขับรถเก่ง
หน้าฟ้าก็เลยให้คุณพ่อขับรถจะไปส่งครูฟ้า
ใช่ไหมค่ะครูฟ้าขับรถไม่เป็นขับรถไม่ได้
นะคะไม่ได้ไม่เป็นเนาะไม่เป็นใช่ขับรถไม่
เป็นเลยจ่ายครูม้าขับเรือเป็นไหมคะ
ขับรถไม่เป็นขับเรือเป็นไหมคะ
ขับเรือ
ไม่เป็นเหรออ่ะเป็นเส้นไม่เป็นแต่กูก็เคย
ขับสปีดโบ๊ทนะเอาอ๋ออ๋อแต่ไฟฟ้าขับ
สปีดโบ๊ทเป็นใต้ค่ะใช่สปีดโบ๊ทเป็นแต่ว่า
เรือแบบนี้ไม่เป็นไม่เป็นถึงที่เป็นลูก
ค้าขับเรือไม่เป็นผู้หญิงขับเรือเป็นไหม
คะครูหญิงเหมือนครูฟ้าค่ะขับเรือไม่เป็น
นะคะไม่เป็น
ไม่เป็นครูฟ้าขับเครื่องบินเป็นไหมคะ
โอ้กูฟ้าขับเครื่องบินเป็นไหม
ถ้าเป็นในเกมไม่ได้จริงๆก็จริงๆมีเครื่อง
บินครูฟ้าเข้าไปนั่งแล้วก็ขับเครื่องบิน
เป็นไว้คะครูพาขับเรื่องดินไม่เป็นค่ะ
เห็น
ผู้หญิงขับเครื่องบินเป็นไหมคะไม่เป็นค่ะ
อ่ะ
คะอันนี้เวอร์เอามันต้องเป็นสกิลที่หาย
ว่างนะขับเครื่องบินนะขับเครื่องบินขับ
เรือใช่ไหมคะแต่ขับรถเนาะขับรถอันนี้โอเค
เรียนได้ใช่ไหมอ่ะนะครับเครื่องบินมัน
ห้องย่าครูฟ้าครูฟ้าเนี่ยอ่ะขับรถไม่เป็น
ใช่ไหมขับเรือไม่เป็นธรรมเครื่องบินไม่
เป็นแต่ครูฟ้าเนี่ยขี่มอเตอร์ไซค์ขี่เป็น
ขี่ได้ได้ปั่นจักรยานหรือว่าขี่จักรยาน
ได้ได้แล้วก็เก่งใช่ค่ะแล้วครูฟ้าขับตุ๊ก
ๆเป็นไหมคะ
ขับตุ๊กตุ๊ก
โตๆๆแล้วครูฟ้ากับตุ๊กเป็นไว้คะอ่ะถ้าขับ
ไม่เป็นฮ่า
ไม่เคยไม่เคยห้างไม่เคยใช่ไหมครูฟ้าเนี่ย
เป็นอันนี้คุณฟ้าแล้วก็ขับเนี่ยไม่เคยแต่
ถ้าครูฟ้านั่งใช่ไหมนั่งตุ๊กตุ๊กอยู่ข้าง
หลังตรงนี้โอเคเคย
นั่ง Only อะนั่งตุ๊กตุ๊ก
ตุ๊กไม่เป็นแต่คิดว่าน่าจะขับลุกได้นะเออ
เนอะคิดนางไปคิดน่าจะว่ามอเตอร์ไซค์ไหม
ผู้หญิงก็คิดนะว่าว่าตุ๊กตุ๊กเนี่ยตุ๊กๆ
เนี่ยนะคะน่าจะเป็นเอ่อมอเตอร์ไซค์แล้วก็
รถทูอินวันคล้ายๆกัน
R เนี่ยอ่ะคะนักเรียนขับอะไร
ก็เป็นบ้างหรือว่าคีย์อะไรเป็นบ้างสมัย
นักเรียนขับรถเป็นไหมคำเรือเป็นไหมคำ
เครื่องบินเป็นไหม
ขับตุ๊กตุ๊กเป็นไหม
ขี่มอเตอร์ไซค์
ขี่จักรยาน
ขี่ม้าได้ไหมก็คอมเม้นท์บอกเราได้นะคะ
ส่วนวันนี้เราสองคนก็ไปก่อนนะแล้วเจอกัน
ใหม่วิดีโอหน้านะคะสวัสดีค่ะถ้า